foreign
if you listen to The Daily cancellation
on Friday then you already knew that
this daily cancellation was coming on
Friday we discussed the idea of
reparations in particular the plan
proposed in California that would Dole
out five million dollars a piece to
Black residents as repayment for the
enslavement that they never experienced
and that nobody they've ever known or
spoken to has experience during that
segment I expanded on a Counterpoint
a Counterpoint to reparations that had
been made by a black college professor
named Wilford Riley which was a
restatement of an argument made by
others Through The Years including
Dinesh D'Souza which says that
reparation proposals are incoherent
because they rest on the speculative
notion that descendants of slaves are in
a worse place today than they otherwise
would have been if their ancestors were
never enslaved now if this speculation
is not accurate if they are not in a
worse spot then there's nothing to
repair
nothing to repair for them anyway
certainly we know that the slave
suffered greatly but the slaves are all
dead so the reparations don't go to them
but rather go to people who again never
experience slavery and so we must ask
what exactly we are repairing as far as
they are concerned
according to this argument which I find
compelling and interesting the more
plausible speculation is that in fact
the ancestors of slaves are in a better
spot today not worse because of slavery
this doesn't justify slavery or make it
okay obviously it simply calls into
question the basic logic behind allowing
a group to literally cash in on
historical atrocities
that's the point
and in an incredibly surprising turn of
events people aren't happy
with this point
and this came as a great shock to me
personally as I'm a people pleaser who
always tries to avoid controversy and
conflict whenever I can but it found me
this time maybe for the first time
starting is always as always with the
requisites Media Matters clip our PR
reps pulled a two-minute slice of the
10-minute monologue did not provide any
context
um didn't even clarify that this was a
conversation about reparations
specifically
and they posted a clip which then went
viral now for reference uh we'll play
the actual video they posted uh so that
you understand where we are what we're
talking about for the rest of the
conversation which again is just one
small sliver of a much longer monologue
where I flesh out all these points and
also explain why I'm making the points
and what the overall point is
but Media Matters never bothers with
silly things like context and they also
know that the drooling hordes who get
worked up by out of context Clips also
aren't going to stop to wonder about the
context
so with that in mind
um here's what I posted
in fact it seems rather clear that black
Americans are doing better here today
than they would be had their ancestors
Generations ago never been brought to
these Shores we can prove this point by
simply asking which African country
anyone asking for reparations would
prefer to live in the answer of course
is none of them now you might offer the
rebuttal that if slavery never existed
if we're reimagining history without
that institution at all then Africa
itself would be in a better shade better
place and better shape and maybe indeed
black Americans would be better off
there but this seems highly unlikely and
it also ignores the fact that Africans
participated in slavery and the slave
trade as much as they were victims of it
not to mention if we're reimagining the
world without African slavery then we
have to also imagine it without all
other forms of global slavery since
African slavery was merely one variety
one offshoot of This Global Institution
and now we have totally in that point
Rewritten the history of the world in a
way so dramatic that it app it's
absolutely impossible to say which
individuals today would end up worse or
better in this alternate universe I mean
if you go back in time and get rid of
slavery from the entire world
you have just it's impossible to say
what the world looks like right now
actually what we can say is that we'd
all end up worse all of us today would
be in a worse spot
if uh slavery never existed at all
across the entire globe
because a change that's significant
would likely shift the course of events
in a way that would mean none of us
would even exist it would be a world
full of other people who are not us
so I know that I benefit today from
virtually everything my ancestors did
and everything did to them because if
any of that had not happened there's a
very good chance that I never would have
come into being and as I see it I
benefit from being if the other option
is not being
well you can already uh imagine the
reaction so we don't need to read
through very many of these but here are
a few people of the thousands who
Express their outrage at a point that it
goes without saying none of them even
attempted to refute Heath Mayo a man who
calls himself a Christian conservative
and who also happens to look exactly
like his name for the record tweeted
this is Ben Shapiro's daily wire and
increasingly you're just a bad person if
you support this know nothing filth with
your subscription dollars Bernice King
the daughter of Martin Luther King Jr
responded and here it is one of the
reasons why some don't want the horrors
of slavery taught in schools because
they don't see it or Jim Crow as an
atrocity but a grotesque statement an
egregious insult to the countless
Africans who perished in the Atlantic or
were enslaved here
of course race hustling show Roland
Martin got his two cents in this
analysis by Matt Walsh is the dumbest
you'll ever see this idiot wants to
opine about the condition of Africa yet
makes no mention of racist white
colonialism hell racist whites redrew
the boundaries of Africa at the 1885
Berlin Conference what
Ali kept it simple pro-slavery a hell of
a plot twist a guy named Ryan mcmaken
posted Walsh has been good on exposing
the dumbness of the whole men can be
women thing but there are not words
sufficient to describe how stupid this
statement about slavery is the argument
is the sort of Arcane trivial mental
masturbation I would expect from a
college freshman philosophy major and
given that his apparent Point here is to
basically say stop saying slavery was so
bad it's a totally bizarre Hill to die
on and there was also a lot of stuff
like this when Matt Walsh eventually
dies a hopefully incredibly horrific
painful death it'll be very cool
watching people celebrate
now I actually agree uh with that last
one not the bit about hoping I die
painfully I you know I prefer not to die
painfully but the second part um I know
that many people will celebrate my death
and I take great pride in that if I if I
spent my life
fighting against the left's cultural
agenda and then I died and they didn't
cheer over my death and mock me as I lay
buried in the ground
that would be a strong indication that I
was incredibly ineffective
the left will will celebrate your death
if they perceive you as a serious threat
and I certainly wish to be a serious
threat
but that aside
um
let me offer a few thoughts in response
to the responses two thoughts to be
precise
first predictably
everybody in the outrage mob accuses me
of arguing that slavery wasn't bad or
that it wasn't an atrocity or that that
it was actually good
I didn't say any of those things nor did
I imply or suggest them in fact I refer
to slavery as an atrocity in the very
segment where Bernice King says I argue
that it wasn't in atrocity obviously I
believe it was atrocity everyone
believes that it's a point so
self-evident and clear that it doesn't
even need to be said
okay it's actually it's it's a it is a
pointless thing to even say because
everyone knows it
there is not a pro-slavery faction in
the modern United States
so there's no need to continually assure
each other that slavery was bad you know
slavery was bad yeah I heard it's bad
it's really bad very very bad it's all
bad it's really bad we know that it's
one of the few things that we all still
know
so when the Pitchfork mob accuses me of
holding the view that slavery wasn't bad
what they mean is that all I'm allowed
to say about slavery is that it was bad
okay they want us to talk about slavery
they definitely want us to talk about it
they want us to harp on it they want us
to go on and on about it just like they
do
but the only thing we're ever allowed to
say is some variation of it was bad
over and over and over again
um if you try to move on to the next
sentence
it was bad end of sentence and then
continue and say something else about it
if you try to articulate some other
thoughts if you try to say anything else
about it you are automatically guilty of
thinking that it's not bad
um
in other words if it was bad isn't your
only thought about slavery
then you don't have that thought about
it at all
so either you either the only thing you
think about slavery is that it was bad
or you think it was good
you're not allowed to have you know
you're only allowed to have one thought
per topic
and this is how they treat slavery it's
how they treat every other subject
they have for every every subject here's
the thought you can have on that
and uh if you're going to talk about it
yeah go ahead and talk about it but only
just say that continue saying that over
and over and over again
this is what makes debate and Dialogue
on the national level totally impossible
not to mention incredibly boring
when we're all just repeating back to
each other the stuff we already know and
has long been established
how can we have a dialogue when you
aren't allowed to develop your thoughts
Beyond this was bad very bad it was so
bad it was so so bad it was the bad
thing it was a really bad thing
you know it wasn't always this day as I
meant as this way as I mentioned Dinesh
D'Souza has been making a similar
argument for years in fact here here he
is on NPR NPR of all places because this
is the kind of thing that you used to be
able to say on NPR
22 years ago
um listen to what he says
as a native of India a country colonized
by the British for centuries and as a
person of color living in the United
States I cannot agree with the idea of
reparations
the concept of reparations is based on
the premise that the descendants of
slavery and colonialism are worse off as
a result of those historical crimes
in reality these descendants are vastly
better off than they would have been had
slavery and colonialism never occurred
let me explain
when I was a young boy growing up in
Bombay I noticed that my grandfather who
had grown up under British colonialism
had developed a strong hostility to the
white man
I realized that he had an anti-white
animus that I didn't share
this puzzled me why did he and I feel so
differently
finally I figured it out the reason for
our difference of perception was that
colonialism had been pretty bad for him
and pretty good for me
another way to put it is that
colonialism had injured those who lived
under it but paradoxically it proved
beneficial to their descendants
virtually everything that I do and
cherish has been shaped by a world view
that was brought to India by colonialism
I write in English I work on a computer
I believe in individual dignity in human
rights in democratic government
inequality before the law in the concept
of innocent until proven guilty all
these things are the product of Western
Civilization
now again
NPR you could say that 22 years ago
now it's the sort of thing that you'll
only ever hear uttered on conservative
media and even there most the time not
and if you do hear it it's shocking it's
utterly shocking now leftists of course
disagreed I would imagine many of them
did
um with that at the time but there
wasn't any nuclear explosion of mindless
outrage with a bunch of slobbering
dummies screaming you support slavery
you think slavery is good
people understood the point that he was
making because it is at a minimum valid
and logical and thoughtful
it also happens to be self-evidently
true
but these days thanks to social media
thanks to the increasing derangement of
the left thanks to plummeting IQ stores
and scores and all the rest of it
um you cannot make valid and logical
arguments because a valid and logical
argument requires you to develop a
thought beyond the one simple shallow
slogan that the left demands we all
consign ourselves to
second you can somewhat understand the
less confusion here I suppose they
firmly believe that the ends justify the
means okay it's one of the core beliefs
of their ideology the ends justify the
means so
um when they hear this discussion they
assume that I'm making an ends justify
the means arguments
because if they were making the argument
that's what they would be doing
if I'm saying that people today have
benefited from historical atrocities I
must be saying that the atrocities were
actually good and Justified because
that's how they think
but that's not how I think okay I think
that there are no results that could
ever retroactively justify an evil Act
let me give you an example
if I were to shoot you and send you to
the hospital
and you don't die and while you're at
the hospital they you know because
they're doing all these tests and
everything they happen to discover
incidentally that you have an aggressive
form of cancer and so they treat the
cancer and you survive
my attempted murder does not
retroactively become a form of medical
treatment
okay it does not become good
now it's true that if I hadn't shot you
you never would have discovered your
cancer perhaps and then or maybe you
discovered it too late
so paradoxically me shooting you
resulted in saving your life
but it was still an act of objective
evil to shoot you
okay so that's the way that works now
here's the thing
if expanding the analogy
if after having your cancer treated you
go on to have children
and then your children have children and
your children's children have children
and many years down the line your
descendants try to sue my descendants
for the generational trauma caused by my
assault against you
well if that were to happen then in that
case it would suddenly become relevant
to point out
that these people claiming damages
decades and decades removed from the
incident probably wouldn't exist their
entire family tree would be erased if
not for the evil act that they are now
trying to cash in on
that's the Crux of it
okay the point that you have most likely
benefited from historical evils becomes
relevant when you attempt to quantify
and monetize the trickle-down harm that
you claim the historical evil has done
to you
it's at that juncture that someone needs
to make the obvious point
this thing that happened long ago was
very very bad it was very bad for your
ancestors it is not however very bad for
you yet you are the one claiming
quantifiable and financial harm
the reparations demands are what makes
this point especially relevant but but
even without reparations there's still
value in acknowledging what we're
talking about here and thinking about it
yes it is true that you likely would not
be here today if history had not
unfolded exactly as it did right the
butterfly effect
The Good the Bad the Ugly the atrocious
all of it led to you and to me
rewrite history and you will have
written us out of the book completely
aside from disqualifying any reparations
demand which I think it does completely
what else does that mean for you well it
simply means that we shouldn't live our
lives obsessed with wrongs committed
long ago consumed by resentment over
ancient sins
it doesn't mean those sins were not sins
okay it doesn't mean that the wrongs
were actually right
it just means that we should stop trying
to make ourselves the victims of the
very events that resulted in our
existence our existence and the most
prosperous and comfortable civilization
in history I might add
we should in a word move on with our
lives
the lives that we are blessed to be
living
because what else is there to do
but just keep living in the moment in
today
that's the point and that's also why the
outrage mob is today once again cancel
that'll do it for this portion of shows
move our members block hope to see you
there if not talk to you on uh tomorrow
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]